resorts world is now officially open for
business the first new property on the
las vegas strip in more than a decade
very exciting night last night and now
the big question is
how much of an economic impact will it
have
orkomana join us live near resorts world
tonight he has that answer about that
economic boost orco
well brian crowds of people filed into
resorts world last night
eager to check out the new property
experts tell us that excitement
paired with new job opportunities is
going to make a lasting impact on las
vegas economy
something we haven't seen in a long time
i think we're going to see a big bump
energizing the economy
gaming historian david g schwartz tells
me resorts world is poised to take las
vegas by storm even more than aria and
the cosmopolitan the last two major
casino openings on the strip
back in 2009 and 2010 respectively
aria cosmo opened up when we were kind
of in the worst part of the
recession now this is opening up as
we're coming out of the pandemic
schwartz says there's pent up demand
right now to check out something shiny
and new
rooms for this weekend at resorts world
are running between 400
and 500 bucks high room rates are a sign
that people are going to spend a lot of
money which means they're going to be
going to restaurants which means they'll
be tipping
a lot the result a big impact to the
local economy that's expected to last a
while
people will continue to be
interested if they've never been there
before i'm pretty optimistic about the
economy going forward resorts world is
also opening with a focus on innovative
technology with huge advances compared
to a decade ago
experts say that'll affect the job
market it brings a new level of talent
here
creates different jobs right it has a
domino effect throughout the tourism
industry
schwartz says that's one of three things
that show if a new resort is successful
is it creating jobs is it bringing in
tax revenue
and you know is it bringing in people
again resorts world just opened about 24
hours ago so we'll need to see how
business does
in the coming months but experts add
with a lot of convention space
and big name residency is the new
property is expected to be a hit
reporting live near resorts world
tonight orca mana 8 news now